Evet
şimdi kazanana kadar kaybetti Eğer beni
buraya bir fotoğrafçı olarak davet
etseydiniz içimden geçeni söyleyeyim
sizlere
karini Tam da burada bu sahnede kırmızı
halının üstünde fotoğraflayıp
fotoğrafını da ekrana yansıtıp 18 dakika
boyunca hiçbir şey konuşmadan durup
çekip gitmek isterdim
Çok
teşekkür ederim ismim Orhan
Evet Ee bu benim işlerimden ilkler
Unutulmaz
1980 Erzincan'a yaklaşık iki saatlik
mesafede Bir köyde dünyaya geldim Bu da
ilkokulum genelde hikayeler hep böyle
başlanılır bu hikayenin bende kalan
tarafı şu burada
aynı derslikte yaklaşık 45 sınıf Eğitim
görürdü yani birler hemen yanında 2'ler
arada bir boşluk Üçler v4l Yani biz
1'inci sınıftan iki sınıfa geçmek için
hemen bir sonraki sıraya geçerdik Şimdi
bazen böyle düşünüyorum bunun
avantajları da var Nasıl avantajları var
mı var aynı zamanda 3. sınıfın
derslerinden dinliyorsunuz bilinçaltında
daha hızlı hareket ediyorsunuz ilkokulda
orada kadar bu okulda okudum ve bir
sıradan bir yerine geçtim hikaye bu
aslında tabii yine burada Bir Hikayem
daha var
biraz yaramaz bir çocukmuşum sıranın
üstündeyim ve her arkadaşım sırayı
çekiyor Ben sıradan betona kafa yerle
bir ben eve gönderiyorlar
yaklaşık 2-3 saat sonra ben bayılıyorum
ve babam apar topar benim köyden ilişki
hastaneye götürüyor
bu hayal meyal hatırlar gibiyim Ama
babam da tazeliyor ve şöyle söylüyor iki
saat içerisinde Biz burada bir şey
yapamayız iki saat içerisinde Erzincan'a
yetiştirdiniz yetiştirdiniz beyin
kanaması geçiriyor yetiştirem ediniz
geri dönün tam olarak cümle bu Bu arada
hastane ilişki hastane bir ampul
ambulans veriyor ve Erzincan'a doğru
yola çıkmaya başlıyoruz kış Bizim
oralarda şunu derler soğuğu sert insanı
mert olur gerçekten kışlar sert geçer ve
Erzincan'da Yola giderken tipi
kitleniyor
bir araya akarak ol giriyor Jandarma
önde yol açıcı bir dozer arkada ambulans
Biz Erzincan'a Vardığımızda 6 saattir
altı saat sonra hastanedeydi kek Neyse
oradan bana kalan en güzel yanı ne
biliyor musunuz en güzel anı diyorum
yaklaşık 14-15 yaşına kadar çekemedim
bu çekemedim Arkadaşlar bu
Ortaokulda tam bir çekemedim lisede
toparlamaya başladım şimdide gayet
iyiyim Bilmiyorum ben söyleyene kadar
farkettiniz mi Ama size bu hikayenin
devamını böyle anlatmayacağım Neden
böyle anlatmayacağım Bu bir giriş
nereden başladık şu soruyla da bir devam
edeyim ve neredeyiz aslında burada olayı
dramatize etmek için bunların hiçbirini
kullanmayacağım Üniversite öğrencileri
el kaldırabilir mi
çok güzel mezunları bir el kaldırabilir
mi Tamam ortalama yaş ortalamamız 19/23
yaş arası değil mi Ben 41 yaşındayım
aramızda ne kadar var
bu yirmi yıl Şimdi ben köyden ayrılırken
ben köyden ayrılırken henüz köylerdeki
evlere su bağlanmıştı yani su ihtiyacını
köyün çeşmesinden getiriyorduk ya da
getiriyorlardı biz daha çocuktuk
Evet şimdi siz daha doğduğunuzda
internetle tanıştınız Biz çok çok
şanslısınız o yüzden
Evet şimdi bir istatistik pas paylaşmak
istiyorum bunun temel sebebi şu 20 yılda
neler değişti
hayatımızda Aslında bunu vermek
istediğim nokta şu bakın Türkiye'deki
2021 istatistiklerinde
65000000 internet kullanıcısı var yani
bundan 20-30 yıl önce evde su olmayan
bir ülkede Bugün artık hepimiz dünyadaki
her bilgiye ulaşabilir durumdayız Bu da
bize hangi değeri üretiyor bugün burada
olmamın sebebi de bu aslında
girişimcilik tarafım hepimizin bildiği
girişimcilikler veya Sabahtan beri
konuşmalarda Dinlediğiniz belki onlarca
tediks konuşmasında ve farklı konuşmalar
da hep bir hikaye var arkadaşlar çalışın
başarın istikrarlı hiç uyumayın Bu
mücadele vereyim
çabalayın ben çok ter döktüm düğme Evet
de siz hiç bir boksörün irilikte
yediği dayağı anlattığını 7 yumruğu
anlattım Duydunuz mu
Eve gidince niye çıkıyor bir mücadele
için değil mi mücadelenin gereği değil
mi o yediği Yumruklar şimdi o yüzden bir
kere bunları büyütmek yerine
kabullenmekle başlayalım Siz halı sahada
iki takımın çok normal bir şekilde diğer
takım tarafı bütün saha yağışlı Hadi gel
gol at dediği bir maç izlediniz mi Hayır
değil mi karşıdaki muhakkak Press
yaptığı durdurdu yakalamaya çalıştı
Demek ki ben şunu söylüyorum kaybedene
kadar kazan bu kaybetmeden de
kazanamayacak mıyız
kaybetmeden de kazanamayacak mıyız bu
arada 18 ekle başlamadı bilginiz olsun
arkaya sesleniyorum
devam ediyorum bugünkü Hikayem Ya da
anlatmak istediğim şey Bir Eğitimci
olarak da ben o topraklardan çıkıp
buraya gelirken ne yaşadıklarım değil
Biz bunu da hep öğrencilerime şöyle
anlatıyorum bizim ne yaşadıklarımız yani
hikayelerini dinleyerek başarılı
olamazsınız arkadaşlar ders çıkartarak
başarılı olursunuz ve ben burada size
çıkarttım dersleri anlatmak istiyorum Bu
on sekiz dakika içerisinde
bunlardan bir tanesi başarısız oluyoruz
Çünkü daha doğrusu kaybediyoruz Çünkü
tam cümle bu kaybediyoruz Çünkü
kaybetmek Evet kaybediyoruz niye
kaybediyoruz ben size birincisini
söyleyeyim birincisini söyleyeyim
sevdiğimiz işleri yapmıyoruz şöyle bir
Düşünsenize
sevdiğiniz bir arkadaşınızla vakit
geçirirken çok uzun süre vakit geçire
biliyorsunuz değil mi ya da sevdiğiniz
bir yemeği karnınız Doyana kadar
yiyorsunuz ama sevmediğiniz bir şey size
ne kadar yorucu geliyor Beş dakika sonra
kurtulmaya çalışıyorsunuz işte iş
hayatınızdaki başarısızlığın en temel
nedeni işi tam olarak sevmiyorsunuz ya
da sevmediğiniz meslekler seçiyorsunuz
bu burada birinci ders ne olursa olsun
sevdiğiniz
sevdiğiniz meslekle vakit geçirin Niye
Çünkü şöyle bir planlayın günün çoğunu
Belki ailenizden sevdiklerinizden daha
fazla işte harcıyorsunuz ve sevdiğiniz
bir şey yapmak oyun gibi gelir ve
başarılı olursunuz iki vardır Bakın bu
mücadelede var ben size şunu söyleyeyim
mutlaka bu yaş ortalaması başaracak
en iyi haber bu yani hepiniz
başaracaksınız arkadaşlar ne kötü haber
ne biliyor musunuz
Sen kaç yaşında başaracaksınız
Evet şimdi
be bu çok konuşmada dinledim bugün
örneklerden biri vardı beni affetsin
şöyle bir durum burada olanlar hemen
hatırlayacaklar hiç yakalayan direkt
yakaladım 65'in de Bodrum'a taşınacağım
yok abi 65'ini Bodrum'a taşınsan ne olur
denize giremezsin Çünkü artık demirin
düşüktü çok üşürsün öyle hareket bir
şekilde barlar sokağında takılamaz sın
Bu yaşına 65'in de başarırsan ne olacak
o yüzden iyi haber hepimiz başaracağız
Selam bugün burada size vermek istediğim
mesaj Mümkünse başarıya 30'larda ya da
40 larda yakalayın ki
gerçekten 65'te yani 60'ında spor araba
aldım üstüne açamıyorum niye Rüzgar
çarpıyor şimdi
ya o yüzden o yüzden söylediklerimin
ikincisi Hep de şu vardır inanın
gerçekten inanarak Bir iş yapmıyoruz
arkadaşlar cümle sözde kalıyor
İnanın
İnanın niye inanın inandırılmış ayın
inanın bakın ayrıştırıyor bir fotoğrafçı
örneğinden vereyim hemen sizi önce
ine ikna edeyim
evet hadi fotoğrafçılığa başladım
sosyalleşir Sen güzel fotoğraf çekersin
ve birkaç şey daha koysam iki Ne oldu ve
benimle birlikte bir arkadaşıyla
birlikte fotoğrafa başlarsınız değil mi
Muhtemelen bugüne kadar başladınız tüm
faaliyetlerde bir Hadi Şunu yapalım hadi
dansa başlayalım biraz eğleniriz Hadi şu
filmi eğleniriz Biz hadi spor yapalım Ha
süper harika ikna edildi Ama devamı
devamı gelmedi
inansaydın muhakkak ve muhakkak
gelirdi i3 Ben bunu eğitimlerinde de
anlatırım Yabancıyız size adım adım bir
şeyin olmasını nasıl olurunu kaybetmeden
nasıl kazanılacağını öğreteyim şimdi bir
soru sorayım özellikle genç kızların da
soralım bu soruyu genç kızlarımıza
soralım Hiç tanımadığınız bir erkek size
gelir ve çıkma teklif ederse Cevabınız
hayır diyenler el kaldırsın
ama çoğunluk
iyi bakın hayır cevabı aldınız bunu işte
de yapmıyor musunuz ilk işe gittiniz
Hayır niye Hayır Çünkü karşı taraf sizi
tanımıyor yabancı sınız yaptığınız işe
de yabancı sınız Peki adım adım
ilerleyelim
Bu ikinci basamak bir buçuk iki ay sonra
aynı çocuk sizi bir yerde gördü ve gene
geldi teklifini yeniledi tekrar
soruyorum
Cevabınız hayır diyenler
mi Evet çoğunluk yine Hayır Niye Çünkü
mü aynı hatayı tekrar yapıyorsunuz
birşey değişmedi bici cevap yine Hayır
şimdi ikinci evreden Sonra ne yapıyoruz
vazgeçip dönüyoruz kazanamadık bir de
bazı Hikayeler var dinliyorum ben de çok
gülüyorum bu konuda 13 ilk et batırdım
beşincisi batırdım on birincisini
batırdım geçenlerde bir 18. sini
batırdım yani batırdım derken kaybettim
abi Onsekiz kere aynı şeyi niye
yapıyorsun bir yerde bir grupta Kendine
bakıp ben acaba teklifi yanlış mı
yapıyorum diye bir sorsaydın
var yani ben Olaya şöyle bakıyorum damla
bile belli bir sürenin sonunda mermeri
Deliyor Yani buradan ne sonuç çıkar
hepimiz başarılı olabiliriz istikrarlı
bir şekilde o Damla olarak Merve
vurursak eğer
Peki işi değiştirin nasıl değiştirin
teklifin formatını değiştirir Çünkü
yabancı sınız Neden Çünkü sizi
tanımıyorlar şöyle düşünün hiçbir teklif
etmediniz Onun çevresinde siniz
dostluğunu kazandığınız çevresine
girdiniz yani yabancı olmaktan çıkıp
tanışık ya da arkadaş oldunuz değil mi
Güzel o zaman hemen teklif mi edelim
Hayır daha tanıdık birbirimizi bir şey
yok onu tanıdıkça ne yaparsınız
ihtiyaçlarını
ve beklentilerini neden Neyi sevip Neyi
sevmediğini görür Ve anlarsınız Öyle
değil mi ve sonra şöyle düşünün çok
sevdiği bir konser ya da atıyorum Cem
Yılmaz'ı çok seviyor Şimdi bir biletle
gittiniz biletle gittin izlerken bakın
burada bir algı oluşturalım iki kişilik
bilet Ama benle git değil al bir
arkadaşınla git şimdi biz algıda çok
sadece şunu anlatırız aklınıza gelecek
kuruyemişçilerde çok yapar manavlarda
bir yere gittiğinizde hemen size bir şey
ikram ederler değil mi
çok dikkat ettiniz mi ve o ikram ettiği
an aldıysanız ondan alma gereği
hissedersiniz yani içgüdüsel olarak
sizin bir şey yapmanızı ister Bunu çok
kullanırlar siz onun için bir şey
yaparsanız Muhtemelen de o sizin için
bir arkadaşıyla gitmek yerine sizi
tercih edecektir Çünkü karşılıksız bir
şey bir hediye verdiniz örnek diyorum
farklı örnekler vereyim mi aklınızda
bulundurun beni tanımıyorsunuz doğum
günüm altı gün sonra hediye alır mısınız
almazsınız ama ben size almış olsaydım
bir sonraki doğum günümde
de oldu mu bu şimdi güzel bir yere
gittik güzel bir yere gittik Okey cem
Yılmaz esprileri patlattı zaten
seviyorum ambiyans Güzel çok keyifli
vakit geçirmeye başladık değil mi
ambiyans güzel keyifli Hatta bunu birkaç
kez tekrarladık sonra aynı arkadaşlara
suyu tekrar sürdüm kız arkadaşlarımıza
soruyoruz Efendim Çok keyifli üç kez
vakit geçirdiğiniz Birimden böyle da
alsaydınız Evet deme olasılığınız ne
olurdu mi Evet diyenler
bu değil mi Artık tanıdığınız Neden
olmasın ilk soru yabancıydı şimdi bu
niye böyle anlattım Çünkü biz yaptığımız
işe tam olarak vakıf değiliz
o ilk denemede İlk denemede bir de
bununla birlikte şu var bildiğimizi
okuyoruz özetle Az önce başıma geldi
Şurada da kokteyl masasında duruyorum
kaybettiğimiz ders çıkartmak için
söylüyorum bunu başka bir yere
bağlayacağım güzel bir örnek oldu masada
duruyoruz Bir tane misafir geldi ya dedi
ki ikramlıklar dan taktınız mı Hangisi
güzel dedi Şimdi biz de fikrimizi
söyledik bir kaç arkadaş birlikteydik
dinledi ben bildiğimi alacağım dedi
Evet şimdi bakın hayatta bu olaya böyle
bakıyoruz Burada ise beni affetsin şimdi
ve bu 30'unda başarılı olmakla
yetmişinde başarılı olmak arasındaki
fark şu tavsiye
Evet arkadaşlar
birilerinin hayatlarından başarı
hikayeleri dinlemeyin o Ören'in
derslerden kendinize pay çıkarttın bakın
Benim iki yaşında bir çocuğum var Düşe
Kalka onu gözlem like o kadar çok şey
öğrendim ki Ne öğrendim ilk adımı
atmanın bir buçuk yıl süreceğini
öğrendim ilk adımı atmanın biz hayatı
nasıl yapıyoruz nasıl öğreniyoruz
bu kadar da hızlı almaya çalışıyoruz
bunu demişken yine bir fotoğrafa
bağlıyım fotoğrafçı olarak lütfen herkes
telefonu çıkartır mı
bu sürem az olunca lütfen varsınlar
buradaki dakika tamam
bir fotoğraf çeker misiniz
mi Evet görelim yiyelim Evet
bu çektiniz mi tamam Gerçek sorunumuz şu
neden diye sormuyoruz
Sen neden diye sormuyoruz
ya bize ne veriliyorsa bize ne veriyorsa
bir konuşma dinledim bir konuşma
dinledim özeti şuydu hızlandırıyor Umeyr
Çin Seddi uydudan gözüküyormuş sonra
araştırmışlar gözükmüyor Muş ama
yıllarca Biz gözüktüğünü düşündük neden
diye sormadık bize bir şey verildiğinde
neden diye sormadık iki
doğduğumuzdan beri doğduğumuzdan beri
elinizde cep telefonları var ve günde
onlarca fotoğraf üretiyorsunuz değil mi
Bir sürü tuşu var orada panoramik çekim
var ağır çekim var yukarıda Işık
ayarları var diyaframı var
arkadaş Hiç merak ettim de bunlar neden
burada var diye sordun mu bir sorsaydın
bugün çok daha etkili bir fotoğraf
çekerdi
ya o yüzden Neden sorusunu sorduğumuz
zaman
öğrenmeye başlıyoruz Şimdi bu
iyi bir fotoğrafçı olarak şöyle hızlı
abone ol
işte bunlar hep bende takılır
bu hikaye bu
bu hikaye Bu bir fotoğrafçı olarak
başarı ve kazanımda bu
bu sonlandırırken
bu ses verebilir miyiz
o belli değil kimseyi göremiyorum yani
Dostlar düşüyor Ailemden bile güzeller
var ama ben çalışıyorum ama ben
bu çalışmayın çalışmayın derken çok
çalışmayı akıllı çalışın güzel çalışın
Her şeyi zamanında yapın zamanında
değerli yani Bodrum'a gitmek zamanında
değerli 20'li yaşlarda eğlenmek
zamanında değerli Ama bu yaşlarda
keyifle eğlenceli çalışırken Yarın
içinde kendinizi hazırlayın ve lütfen
Neden sorusunu sorun teşekkür ediyorum